-Our next guest is a talente
actress and comedian,
known from shows
like "Parks and Recreation
and films like "Obvious Child.
The paperback edition
of her book "Little Weirds
is available now.
Please welcome back to the show,
our friend, Jenny Slate.
Hi, Jenny!
-Hi, Seth!
-It's so lovely to see you
It's been about a year
since we've crossed paths.
It's been about nine month
since the world shut down.
How have
your last nine months been
-Whu--
Well -- [ Sighs ]
Let me tell you,
on night one of the lockdown
we had a really, like, romanti
night of being together.
Um, real sweet with my fiancé.
And then, I did
what everyone else did.
I kind of, like, hunkered down
and baked a lot of bread,
but I just want to say,
I think --
I think I might have baked
like, too much bread
or eaten too much bread.
You tell me, Seth.
But I think...
[ Laughter ]
-I can't really --
-Oh!
Oh, yeah!
-Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know if you can see --
-Oh, yeah,
that's a lot of carbs.
[ Laughter ]
-It's different.
It's, like, different.
-[ Laughing ]
It feels -- I feel different
[ Both laugh ]
Um, how have the exact
last nine months been?
-Oh, my God.
-They've been, um...
real pregnant for me.
-That's amazing.
Now, I will say, you know,
my wife, Alexi, has said, like
that people
who timed it like you,
she feels, like,
crushed the timing.
Like, because you basicall
had to hunker down anyway.
Have you felt, like,
"Oh, this was a fortuitous tim
to do this"?
-You know, in a way --
First of all, it's very nice
to have something
that is incredibly positiv
during a time
that's, like, hard and sad
It's nice to have, like,
a little secret treasure.
Um, but, yeah, I mean, like,
I've basically been
just chilling out.
Doing exactly
what I wanted to do.
Not having to see anyone
or figure out, like,
how to gracefully wear pants
I haven't worn pants
in many moons.
You know?
[ Laughter ]
And, also, like,
spending an hour of my day
doing, like, a hypno-birthin
meditation every day.
So I'm very chill.
-Gotcha.
So you found your way,
even during a pandemic,
to find the time to do the
sort of birthing-class stuff
-[ Laughing ] Yeah, it's nice.
I mean, it's so --
Everything is weird.
Like, this isn't what
I thought I would be doing
But, like, one thing I do --
I do all the birth-prep stuff,
and I really like it.
I'm also, like --
Many of my friends
will remind me
that I am the number-one perso
who would join a cult, like,
without even
having to be pressured.
[ Both laugh ]
Like, I love chill vibes,
and I like it when someone seems
like they have the answer.
But I've been listening
to this doctor who --
I think she's from India
but has lived in England
for a while -- that's what I'm
getting from her accent.
And I listen to her every day,
and she said things like,
"Take your attention to your
liver, kidneys, and 'co-lon.'"
[ Laughter ]
-'Co-lon.'
That means colon.
-Yeah.
You -- have you guys been on the
East Coast during this time?
-Yeah, we've been
in Massachusetts,
in a beautiful tiny little
seaside town where we live
And just my luck,
I moved in with my fiancé,
and, of course, he lives in,
like, a very old house that is
I think, most certainly haunte
and has an actual pet cemetery
-A real pet cemetery?
-Yeah.
-Like, based on the fact that,
over the years,
this house has had
that many befallen pets?
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
I mean,
they didn't get murdered.
I think they all kind of
went their way,
and then they died,
and then they buried them,
but it has been in my fiancé
Ben's family, like,
since the '30s, I think.
So, it's, you know,
like 90 years of pets.
And it's like,
they're all little fancy guy
like cocker spaniels and stuff
And at the start
of the pandemic,
when I was, like,
just newly pregnant,
I started to go out and visi
the pet cemetery every day
And Ben told me that, like
I started saying things like
"I'm just gonna go outside
and visit the pets."
[ Both laugh ]
It was like --
I think it's like --
It's, like -- That's, like
how a scary movie starts.
-Yeah.
-You know, like,
a pregnant lady is like,
"My pets.
My precious, precious pets."
[ Both laugh ]
-You -- You've thrived as
an artist during this time
I did not know
your sort of visual skills
-Yeah.
-I guess this was to like --
You had a chalkboard and thi
was, like, to mark the days?
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
Yeah. Okay, okay.
So, what this is --
is that I felt like,
at the start of the pandemic
it's, like, hard to keep track
of the days after a while.
If you don't -- If you're, like,
kind of just in your house
and you don't have --
You're like an actor
who has no set to go to.
So, I started to write the days,
and draw a picture,
and then that
devolved into this --
or evolved into this cartoon
that is about our new dog
that we adopted
and a brontosaurus
who loves her.
-Yeah.
So, on Thursday,
for those of you who can't read,
the brontosaurus is saying
"Sally, I love you.
Do you love me?"
And Sally's agreeing and saying,
"I love you."
-Yeah.
-And then, on Friday,
"Do you want
to go on a trip with me?"
Right?
-Yeah.
-And then, the following Monday,
now it's lundi.
It's lundi,
and they're in Paris.
That's beautiful.
-Yeah.
Yeah,
they traveled over the weekend
and I guess I didn't
take any pictures
of what happened on the weekend.
But there was one of Sally
packing a suitcase
filled with bones,
and, like, saying like,
"Give me some hints.
I don't know what to pack.
Um, and then, Sunday was the
on a very crudely drawn --
It was like a bicycle, I guess
And Ben is very charitable
towards me,
and I'm a terrible
visual artist.
He's a really good one.
But he, like, congratulates me
every day and tells me it's --
like, they're
really, really good.
-That's very --
That is very lovely of him
Um, your book
is very, very good.
We've talked about it before
and now it's in paperback.
What is it like to revisit
a book that is really funn
but also really vulnerable
in this time
that I think has been really
vulnerable for a lot of people
particularly those who might
pick it up and read it?
-Yeah.
I mean, it is a nice --
It's actually --
I mean, it's a plug.
But it is a nice book to rea
now because I wrote it
during a time
when I was kind of, like,
trying to work through
sad feelings
and trying to figure out
how to be alone
in a way that didn't feel scar
or like a punishment.
And then, we sort of all
had to be alone,
in one way or another,
for so many months now.
And I think it's --
it's sometimes just, like, har
to find a little bit
of positivity in that.
But I think the book,
it's all these little pieces
about my feelings
during those times.
But I think -- I think kind of
anyone could read them
and find something
to get for themselves.
But it's -- it's just that
when I finish the book,
the last chapter
is sort of like,
"And I'm a woman alone,
and I will be alone now."
And then, like, a month later,
I fell in love,
and now I'm pregnant.
[ Both laugh ]
It's not --
It's a happy ending.
I just didn't expect it
to be so happy and so soon
-Well, it is.
We're so happy that it is
that ending for you.
You more than deserve it.
And it's always just such
a delight to see you, Jenny.
Thanks so much for being here.
-Thanks for having me, Seth.
It's nice to be here.